it's like long blonde I don't think I've
played this person before I would have
played in Alekhine also what what is uh
what is a plan planning variation I
don't think I've heard of that before
let's place Maura smith Laura Smith for
a time I'm playing jock Sica maybe okay
Smith more accepted have to make a
sermon proud and John proud two knights
developed Bishop c4 this is still some
theory ie five I think this is supposed
to be very good I don't think I've ever
like studied this specifically I'm
trying to remember I know 95s a move but
I think Knight d5 occurs after the Queen
trade and it's also this line there's
two different captures for black I
remember seeing John playing a game
where he was who's he playing John
didn't you have this against helmsman
Helms my played Knights g7 and John
Blade II six just had such a nice
position okay let's take oath heirs some
fancy meet coming up it depends what
black does so if that move I have this
move I'm very hard to defend f7
if night if the night were to take I
would have gone after c7 as calculating
night takes here and like b5 kindy 7 I
takes e5 King us to go back and then 97
mates would have been nice but this is
also nice remember I play the tournament
ooh Bishop e6 played the spice Cup very
high level tournaments my friends who's
international master know there's
rejects f17 takes f7 the knight defense
of Queen very important so that would
have lost a piece for me but good
question
yeah Knights can can move backwards it
crossed my mind though that I wanted to
go for the tactic but yeah my
international master friend fell for for
the sinus black lost maybe like a 2100
play knife 7 3 reversible Knights what
does that mean
reversible Knights
Wow look at these triple pawns Sony
triple pawns
okay I'm forking couple pawns at some
point I want to play Knight b5 I also
want to take on e6 I also want a
queenside castle with mates so many
things I want for Christmas
christmas has passed but the gifts don't
start coming okay let's start with night
before let's start with maybe five maybe
five King g7 let's start with this night
is joining the party hmm interesting
watch a hot King defy he played I'm not
seeing the at least the Queen's I castle
with mates it's close it's very close I
mean let's throw in another check
I mean the king kid could walk further
up doesn't want to walk further can't
blame him oh let's just take a look what
to do check oh now the king wants to
walk further up
I have to play like one preparatory move
and this move
no that stops me from doing what I
wanted to do I'll take a pawn wait check
wait where's a mate oh here's okay
here's simple plan oh man too much fun I
feel like my opponents just want to like
want to be famous on YouTube it's
working it is working Wow want to finish
it's a second game castling with meets
the previous one was was also kind of
like this okay I guess I'll put that on
YouTube YouTube people thanks for
watching remember to Castle
it makes your King safe and sometimes it
made slip-ons King